>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Betsy Peterson: All right.
We have a jam-packed
evening here.
So, I'm just going to dive
right in and get started.
So, I am Betsy Peterson.
I'm the director of the
American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress
and I'd like to welcome you
to a very special edition of the
Benjamin Botkin lecture series.
This evening, in various ways,
we're going to explore the
legacy of a very special person
in the history of the
library, in the history
of the American Folklife
Center, Alan Jabbour.
Alan passed away on January
13th, 2017, and I'm happy to see
so many familiar faces and also
many family members of Alan
and Karen Jabbour are here and I
especially want to welcome them
and I will actually
probably let you stand
and if I do not get all of
your names, please forgive me,
but I want Karen Singer Jabbour
and daughter Rebecca and Aaron,
daughters, daughter and son of
Alan and Karen, please stand.
And their spouse and children.
I know there are many
siblings of Karen
and I think there are
family members of Alan here.
So, please stand up.
We would love to say
thank you and welcome.
[ Background noise ]
>> Betsy Peterson: Before
introducing the speakers,
I want to say as we know,
Alan was the founding director
of the American Folklife
Center and in that role,
he was a direct successor
to Benjamin Botkin,
head of the library's
folklore section in the 1940's.
So, it's appropriate that we're
presenting this evening event
of talks and music about
Alan as part of this series.
This series also allows us to
present the, and highlight,
the work of the best
in leading scholars,
experts in the disciplines of
folklore at the musicology,
oral history, and
cultural heritage.
It also allows us to
enhance the collections
of the American Folklife
Center, and for the center
and the library, the Botkin
lectures form an important facet
of our acquisitions activities.
Each lecture is videotaped
as you can gather,
with these bright lights,
and it becomes part
of the permanent
collections of the center.
So, the lectures are going to
be posted later as a webcast
on the libraries website
where they will be available
to people throughout the world
and for generations to come.
So, if you have noisy cellphones
on right now or anything
that might ring later, please
turn it off at this time.
So, Alan, being the director of
the American Folklife Center,
from 1976, I think September
of 1976 through June of 1999,
that was only one of many roles
that Alan assumed throughout
his lifetime in his efforts
to preserve and carry forward
folk cultural traditions.
Alan was a musician, an
artist, a native Floridian,
a southern gentleman, a writer,
an administrator with a vision,
folklorist, researcher,
president of the
American Folklore Society,
a member of numerous
boards and so much more.
Our speakers this evening
will be addressing many
of these different facets and
aspects of Alan's contributions,
but before I introduce
them I did want
to mention one dimension
of Alan's work
that I think has received very
little attention over the years
and that is Alan's work to raise
the profile of philanthropy
and giving for the folk
and traditional arts.
Alan came to D.C and the
federal government in the 1970's
and we know that
was a very heaty
and sometimes turbulent
time for cultural heritage
and preservation legislation
and government support and Alan
and several other folklore
luminaries at that time,
Archie Green, Bess Lomax
Hawes, and Ralph Rinzler,
among them were right
there at the very beginning
and they helped build
this foundation
for several public
folklore institutions
and perhaps Alan's work at the
national endowment for the arts
as an initial head of the folk
arts program provided him a
window for him to understand
the importance of support.
And not only to provide
needed financial resources,
but also to lend legitimacy
and validation to the diversity
of folk and traditional culture
in the United States and beyond.
But, with so much emphasis on
public support, Alan and others,
Joe Wilson, Archie Green,
also recognized the critical
importance of galvanizing
and strengthening private
and individual support
for the grass roots
vernacular culture
that we all hold so dear.
Alan and others helped to
find the fund for folk culture
in 1991 and held the
planning meetings right here
in the library.
Alan was the first chair of
the board of trustees and in
that capacity, helped guide
the direction of that fund
to help serve as an advocate and
liaison for the field of folk
and traditional arts with
private philanthropy.
In that role, over about a
15-year span, they steered over,
well over $10 million
dollars of new support
to the folk arts field which is
pretty amazing and in his work
at the folklife center,
Alan also established several
endowments and gift funds
to support the work of
the center and others
and individuals to
do their work.
The Ray Virginia Alan fund, the
Blant Nolan fund, the Gerald
and Karen Parson's
fund and of course,
the Henry Reed fund
for folk artists.
On the occasion of
Alan's retirement,
Alan and Karen Jabbour, with
several other individuals,
established the fund, the
Henry Reed fund in 2000.
It honors Alan's musical mentor,
West Virginia fiddler Henry Reed
and provides support
for folk artists
or to projects benefiting folk
artists whether it be a program,
a recording project, a,
providing opportunities
for artists to do research and
to work with other artists.
Since 2004, the Henry Reed
fund has provided awards
to 10 individuals and I know we
have several individuals here
tonight, perhaps some
Henry Reed recipients,
but I know we also have many
individuals who have given
to the Henry Reed
fund and I truly want
to thank you for doing that.
I also want to acknowledge
Henry Reed's son,
Dean Reed who is
here with us tonight
and Henry Reed's
grandson, Terry,
if you would stand
up we would love to.
[ Background noise ]
>> Betsy Peterson: And I
also want to encourage if any
of you are feeling that you
want to extend Alan's legacy
and honor Alan's
legacy by contributing
to the Henry Reed fund, there
is a flier outside the door
that will give you
the information
about how to do that.
Please feel free to talk
to me or any staff member
and actually, that reminds
me while I am up here
to thank all the American
Folklife Center staff
for all the incredible
work they've done
to put this together.
They all, very much,
all of us, very much,
want to honor Alan's legacy.
So, thank you American
Folklife Center staff,
but now on with the program.
To tell you more about
Alan and the work
that these individuals have
done with Alan over the years,
we do have several
friends, research partners,
family who are going
to share their memories
and observations
with us tonight.
We are also going to end with
a great old-time music jam
which I think is very fitting.
Many of us have spent time with
Alan very late into the night
and early morning listening
or playing music with him.
So, I think it's only fitting
that we end this
evening with that.
We will be making announcements
about that and what to do.
I know Athea already
mentioned property passes.
It's very important as
I'm sure some of you know.
So, our first speaker is
going to be CARL FLEISHHAUER
and Carl was one of
the first employees
of the American Folklife
Center and one
of Alan's closest
collaborators for decades.
He was a field worker on many
of American Folklife Center's
documentation projects
in the 1970's and 80's.
In the old-time music
world, he was crucial
to documenting the Hammond's
family, which was a project
that he worked on with Alan.
He's also knows as a top
bluegrass photographer
and has published a book.
Prior to his recent retirement,
he worked on various aspects
of digital preservation
in the Library of Congress
and that's actually probably
putting that very mildly.
He was instrumental to
bringing digital preservation
to the library.
He has now returned to the
American Folklife Center
as a volunteer, yay, and working
on the digital preservation
of American Folklife
Center field work projects,
which is a series of
projects that Alan
and Carl spearheaded
and masterminded.
So, without further ado, please
lets welcome CARL FLEISHHAUER.
[ Background noise ]
>> CARL FLEISHHAUER:
Thank you Betsy
and I'm pleased to be here.
What I'm going to talk
about, as Betsy suggested,
is Alan as the leader of
the center from the start.
A little about his thinking,
activities at the center
and policy development in
federal, cultural sector.
The study and performance
of music that Alan did
so well will be the subject
of the next presentations.
Let me start with Alan
and strategic planning.
This is a bureaucratic
exorcise that tends
to repeat at regular intervals.
I should know after 40 years
here at the library proceeded
by working a university and on
the boards of some non-profits.
All too often, staff or
board members are put
through agonizing
committee discussions
that eagled impenetrable
documents written
in bureaucratese.
Not so with Alan.
Even as the center first took
shape, planning moved forward
in semiformal 2-way
conversations
with the center staff and
the folklife center board.
Alan listened as much
as he imparted insights
and information.
He was an inveterate
telephone caller,
especially before
email was prevalent.
As ideas took shape, Alan
had 2 advantages over most
of his conversation
partners, solid experience
at the library gained when
he was head of the archive
of folksong from 1969
to 1974 and a sense
of the federal context for
cultural activities resulting
from his work at the
library and as the head
of the new folk arts program
at the national endowment
for the arts from 74 to 76.
That work was under the
estimable chairman Nancy Hanks
and I remember a
conversation from that period.
Here's how it works
Carl, Alan said,
if the letter awards a
grant, Nancy signs it.
If it says no, we're
sorry, then I sign it.
Translating plans into action
sometimes required staff members
to read before the lines.
For important matters,
of course, Alan conferred
with the center's board and with
the library chain of command,
often but not always, aligned
with one another, but for staff
like me, some actions
just seemed to happen.
You could be surprised.
Of course, usually,
they had been heralded
by earlier discussion
and marched in step
with the center's mission.
Archie Green's excellent
wording embedded
in the center's enabling
legislation,
but here's an example.
Alan's academic background
was rooted in music
and ballad scholarship
and he wanted
to be sure the center's
program was as broad
as the term folk life.
Actions to advance this
goal popped into view
in Alan's earlier hiring.
Adding Rusty Marshall
to the staff.
Rusty had been a student of
Henry Glassy and was immersed
in folk architecture
and material culture
and Elena [inaudible],
a Lithuanian American
with great insights into the
evolving expressive culture
of those who came from Europe.
There was also carry over from a
project that Alan helped launch
when he was at the archive.
[inaudible] Spots was folk
music of America record albums.
Work that flowed into one
of the new center's first public
events, symposium and book,
ethnic recording in America.
Speaking of ethnicity,
Alan rarely talked
about his own family history,
but in 2007, a writer picked
up his remarks about
his field work
with the Virginia
fiddler Henry Reed.
Reed's father had immigrated
from Ireland while Alan's
had come from Syria.
Quote, your family story telling
creates a felt connection
between your past
and your present life
in America, Alan said.
It's curious that my father
was the immigrant and I ended
up being the most
attentive person
to certain cultural
traditions here.
Regarding communication,
Alan's descriptions
of the center's accomplishments
showed a real knack
for putting a range of
events and activities
into a coherent statement.
The quarterly newsletter was
an excellent vehicle for this
and other topics and for about
10 years, Alan made good use
of the director's column.
He once said, the newsletter
gives you news and views
and people tell me the views
are the most interesting.
On 3 occasions, Alan
drafted reviews
of the center's accomplishments.
Short ones at the 5 and
10-year marks in 1981 and 1986
and 17,000 word offering
for the 20th in 1996.
Free of bureaucratic jargon,
these reports paint a picture
of a successive, successful
program, upbeat and affirming
to be sure and here we
tip the hat to Jim Hardon
who edited the newsletter
through this period.
The center's agenda
reflected a range
of advice from multiple voices.
Nevertheless, Alan was the
nerve center for the ideas
that were translated
into action.
Some were topical
like ethnic groups
and material culture while
others concerned activities.
For example, exhibitions,
publications and concerts.
The first concert was
staged within weeks
of the center's establishment.
When Alan wrote about
it 20 years later,
he signaled the value of
the series not only in terms
of artistic expression and the
celebration of community arts,
but also in terms of
support for institutional
and congressional relations.
The audience, Alan said, was
quote, dominated by library
and capitol hill staffers,
making it for years,
the center's public
face on the hill.
Alan guided the center to other
forms of public communication
such as a CD publishing
venture with Rounder Records
and during Alan's first decade
as director, the center began
to provide access
via the internet.
Finding aids before the
immergence of the world wide web
and after 1994,
online multimedia collections
accessed via the web.
Exhibitions illuminated subjects
ranging from ethnic recording
to Nevada Buckaroos here
with the Smithsonian
to folk life in Rhode Island.
A photo display in the U.S
senate office building.
Exhibits provided visibility
not only for the senate,
but also with the white house.
First lady Rosalynn Carter
and daughter Amy opened an
installation on Georgia folk art
and folk life in 1978,
while president Mrs. Regan
opened the American Cowboy
Exhibition in 1983.
During the 1980's, the center
director Alan attended meetings
of the world intellectual
property organization
to discuss intellectual
property and folk expression.
His article for UNESCO's
copyright bulletin noted
that copyright law focused on
the rights of an individual
or incorporated entity in
contrast to the way that,
in many tradition communities,
creative expression is seen
as belonging to groups.
[ Background noise ]
>> CARL FLEISHHAUER:
Protecting folklore, Alan wrote,
means acknowledging
an intermediate sphere
of intellectual property rights
between individual rights
on the one hand and
the national,
international public
domain on the other in terms
of legal history and
legal frameworks,
this is a radical idea.
Meanwhile, as we look back,
our attention is often drawn
to the center's field
work projects.
Alan staged more than a
dozen from 1977 to 1994,
rural and urban like this New
Jersey pair in the pinelands
and in industrial Patterson.
These were team projects
with mostly youthful workers
although the 1979 team
in Rhode Island included
professor Kenny Goldstein,
wearing the white shirt in
this team meeting in a project
that was led by our recently
departed college Peter Bardis.
May he rest in peace.
These were generally survey
projects lasting a month or 2.
Some cooperatively with
the national park service,
some with state arts councils.
Alan often visited
and participated.
Field projects were integrated
into the center's program
in addition to exhibits,
products included David Taylor's
book on Italian Americans
in the west from a
multistate survey,
Charles Woolf's double album
of Blueridge religious music,
and Mary Huffard's
evocative web collections
from West Virginia's
coal fields and more.
Meanwhile, for Native
American music,
the federal cylinder
preservation project came first,
field work came second.
Cylinder recordings of the
Omaha Tribe were created
by Alice Fletcher and Francis La
Flesche between 1895 and 1905.
In 1983, Alan visited the
Omaha Indian reservation
to share copies with the tribal
council and to seek agreement
on selection and publication.
When he played some examples,
2 elderly men were present.
When John Turner began
singing, Alan wrote,
I knew we were home free.
Soon, the center
published album,
documented 2 Omaha powwows,
created a website and co-hosted
by the tribe's cultural
representative,
staged a performance
at the library.
The field work projects
contributed
to policy development,
most strikingly in relation
to historic preservation
where the federal legal
apparatus expanded
from the 1960's to the
1990's with a fresh interest
in what was called intangible
elements of cultural heritage.
In 1977 and 78, national park
service director William Wayland
was on the center's
board and Alan worked
with park service
representatives to frame
up a field project on
the Blueridge parkway
to provide material for
park interpretive programs.
In later cooperative projects
like the 1983 pinelands
folklife project in New Jersey,
the center provided not only
support for interpretation,
but also for park service
planning efforts including land
use concepts that were sensitive
to neighboring communities.
By the 1980's, Alan wrote,
national park service
planners quote,
represent a new generation
of professionals
who have been gradually
abandoning the acquire control
and manage model for national
parks and exploring models
for cooperation with local
communities operating
on the premise that local people
should be enlisted, not evicted.
In 1985, the center joined
Utah's Historic Preservation
Agency to carry out a field
project in Grouse Creek.
In the 1987 a park service
project in Iowa Massachusetts.
Meanwhile, the impact
of the early field projects
influenced the center's
recommendations concerning
historic preservation policy
in Ormand Loomis's 1983
report, cultural conservation,
the protection of cultural
heritage in the United States.
The field projects added
to the library's holdings
of archival collections.
Their organization, description,
and preservation
received a boost in 1978
when the folk archive was
brought into the center.
Founded by Robert
Gordan in 1928,
the archive had long been part
of the library's music division.
Alan used his skills as
a diplomat and negotiator
to find an acceptable
arrangement
for that administrative move.
When Alan talked about
the field work projects,
he emphasized their debt
to New Deal era work,
the federal writer's project,
photography from the foreign
security administration
and of course, the work
of John and Alan Lomax
and their cohorts,
Herbert Halpert,
Sidney Robertson Cowell, Ben
Botkin, and Charles Seeger,
a personal favorite of Alan's.
These predecessors, Alan wrote,
modeled quote, a
documentary cycle.
Field work, collection building
and subsequent public outreach
and as we have seen, Alan pushed
the center quoting him again
to recycle documents
back into cultural use.
[ Background noise ]
>> CARL FLEISHHAUER: Alan
continued to enact this cycle
in his retirement years
in the great Smoky
Mountains National Park.
Alan, Ted Coil, and Karen Singer
Jabbour documented cemetery
traditions, especially the
celebration of Decoration Day.
The work was initially for an
environmental impact statement.
A push for the recognition
of non-Native American
tradition cultural properties
in the environmental
impact process.
Alan's work with Karen Singer
Jabbour, his wife of 55 years,
represented documentary
recycling of another sort.
Repeating their teamwork
from the 1960's when Karen
and Alan visited the
Virginia fiddler Henry Reed
and other folk musicians.
Their joint effort in the
2000's yielded their engaging
and thoughtful book,
Decoration Day in the Mountains.
I'll close with a paraphrase
of Alan's own tribute
to Ben Botkin, the man from whom
this lecture series is named.
Adjusting the words, a bit
to celebrate Alan's
final phase of life.
His official Washington
career was over.
Neither his personal
accounts, nor those of others,
suggest any deep
unhappiness with the tensions
of administrative life
in the federal maw.
He continued to be
a public folklorist,
now in a private capacity.
It had been a vigorous period in
the American cultural enterprise
and both Alan Jabbour
as an individual
and the American Folklife Center
as a cultural institution,
were at the very
epicenter of the enterprise.
Thank you.
[ Background noise ]
>> Betsy Peterson:
Thanks so much Carl.
That was wonderful
and it's wonderful
to see all these incredible
photographs and the photographs
that we saw earlier during the
reception, many of those are
from the field survey projects
that Alan and Carl did.
Now, we are on to
our next speaker,
a gentleman named
DAVID DURCHGOTT
and who I have not
personally met,
but I know he is a contributor
to the Henry Reed fund
and also runs an organization
that Alan served on,
on the board, International
Arts and Artists.
Sort of going back to some
of the comments that
I made earlier.
So, David, welcome.
[ Background noise ]
>> DAVID DURCHGOTT: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
In 1974, I was working for the
South Carolina Arts Commission
and my responsibilities there
included coordinating the first
national endowment for the
arts funded multistate project.
We were documenting
the local folk ways
of the South Carolina low
country using methodology
which would be simultaneously
used
in Mississippi and Kentucky.
Alan is the director
of the nation endowment
for the arts new
folk art program flew
to South Carolina to meet me.
I picked him up at the Columbia
airport and we drove 2 hours
to Charleston to
view the programs.
That drive and conversation
was fascinating.
It was my first exposure to Alan
and like practically every other
conversation we had throughout
the subsequent 42-year
friendship, it was enlightening
in an era prior to the
internet and Google,
Alan was not only familiar with
music and the material culture
of Charleston, my hometown,
but then he also knew
about my family's history
and historic connection
to Jacksonville, his hometown.
I never left a conversation
with Alan
without learning something new.
His interests were broad and
his knowledge was encyclopedic
and thinking back to that 2-hour
drive in our original meeting,
I later realized
that I could've,
he could've easily flown
directly to Charleston
to meet me there, but I'm sure
that Alan wanted that car time
to get to know who I was.
Within the context of this
tribute to Alan's legacy,
I felt it was very important
to mention the breadth
of Alan's impact went far
beyond the traditional music
and folklife communities
that he loved so dearly.
In his work as the
first director
of the folk arts program
at the NEA in 1974 to 1976,
Alan helped millions bring the
arts to millions and millions
of people and he did it in a
way that they could understand,
touching the very fiber of who
they were and where they were.
Additionally, Alan personally
and directly affected the lives
of 100's of people like me, who
were then working across the U.S
as we could to carry
that same message.
Here, in D.C., Alan
was on the board
and co-chaired the humanities
D.C., which was from 1987
to 1988 which is
the local affiliate
of the national endowment
for the humanities.
Nationally, he also helped
organize the alliance
for American Quilts
from 2001 to 2007
and he facilitated starting
the Quilt Alliance's national
documentation index.
He served on the
boards of the Alliance
of the National Heritage
Areas, the European Center
for Traditional Cultures,
and shared the fun for folk,
fun for folk culture, as Carl
mentioned, from 1991 to 1994.
And closest to me, Alan
served on the board
of International Arts
and Artists for 14 years.
He was our board chair for 7 and
a half years, 3 successive years
at the terms May 25th of 2009
until his death last year.
He guided International Arts
and Artists, an organization
that focuses on sharing
cultures, through the recession
and with, through a lot
of organizational growth.
He encouraged the
organization to reach
out to the broadest range of
cultures from other nations
as well as to all
American ethnicities.
We lived around the corner from
each other as well for 25 years.
[ Background noise ]
Throughout all of these
involvements, in every aspect
of his life, Alan was
demanding of himself,
and yet showed tremendous
kindness
and patience with others.
He was [inaudible] and yet
in the most folksy manner.
He always spoke endearingly
and proudly of his children,
his love of Karen, and his
appreciation of her intellect.
And her unwavering support
was evident throughout their
remarkable half century
of marriage.
I wanted to thank him in front
of everyone, a dear friend,
who I'll miss greatly.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Betsy Peterson:
Thank you, David.
Now I want to call up to
the stage Ken Perlman,
who many of you know, and
was also a partner of Alan's,
and is considered to be one
of the top claw hammer
banjo players in the world.
Known in particular for
his skillful adaptations
of Celtic tunes to the style.
And he draws his material
from traditional sources,
including the music of
Scotland, Ireland, Cape Britain,
Prince Edward Island
and the American South.
But his approach to the
music is highly innovative.
Also, as an active
folklorist, Ken has spent
over 2 decades collecting
tunes and oral histories
from traditional fiddle
players on Prince Edward Island
and Eastern Canada, which
has resulted in 2 books
and a 2 CD anthology
of field recordings.
He has toured throughout most
of the English speaking world,
sometimes with Alan,
and in Western Europe,
both as a soloist,
and for over 15 years,
in a duo with Alan Jabbour.
So, oh, you are right behind me.
Okay. I didn't know if I needed
to kind of stall, but I don't.
So, without further
adieu, Ken Perlman.
[ Applause ]
>> Ken Perlman: Well,
thank you, so much.
Before I start, I'd like
to thank Karen Jabbour
for the great honor of speaking
here to remember Alan in front
of so many wonderful people.
Alan and I toured together,
okay, this is the, okay, got it.
Sorry. Technology.
Alan and I toured together
for nearly 15 years.
We first encountered each
other, musically, in August 2000
at a music camp in the Rockies.
His official accompanist
bowed out at the last minuted,
and given that I was the
resident old time banjo picker,
he asked me to accompany
him in his concert set.
From the moment he
touched bow to string,
and we started playing together,
there was a strong musical
affinity, an uncanny blend
of fiddle tone with banjo
tone, along with a sharing
of sensibilities and tastes.
His approach was strong
and powerfully rhythmic,
but fully lyrical and delicately
phrased, even charming.
As soon as I heard him interpret
a tune, even one I had heard
around the scene for years,
that instantly became the
definitive version for me,
and one I wanted to emulate.
He inspired me, not only
to learn many dozens
of his tunes note for note,
but to develop a whole new way
to accompany them that fit
his style like a glove.
This melding of fiddle and banjo
can be heard on our first CD,
Southern Summits, and jointed by
guitarist Jim Watson, I guess,
who couldn't make it
at the last minute,
he as going to be here
tonight,on the CD,
You Can't Beat the Classics,
which was completed just a
few months before the onset
of Alan's last illness.
I'd like to go back to
slide 2 for a minute,
and here's a little
sample of the sound
that we developed together,
a tune called Waynesboro,
just a little excerpt.
[ Music ]
[ Background noise ]
[ Applause ]
I can still remember
our recording it, here,
in Washington, 10 years ago.
After a few visits
back and forth,
Alan and I started
touring, and until the state
of his health intervened,
we toured or worked together
at music camps at least
3 or 4 times a year.
Our travels took us to England,
Ireland, Scotland and Shetland,
Western Europe and Canada,
but mostly we toured
regionally in the United States.
Depending on the season,
our travels took us
to the Northeast, or
his native South Land,
the Pacific Coast,
or the Midwest.
In what was probably our longest
tour, in the fall of 2010,
we started out in Atlanta,
curved through Alabama,
Tennessee and Kentucky,
on up into Michigan,
headed northwest past
Chicago to Madison,
and then back to
D.C. via Indiana.
[ Background noise ]
And here's another
picture from that era.
Touring with Alan was an
eye-opening experience.
He was a much loved
and respected figure,
renowned not only in the folk
and acoustic music worlds,
but also in the world
of academic folklore,
as you've heard.
Even in a world of perfect,
and near, strangers,
he had only to walk in
to command attention.
And most folks would emerge
from any given social occasion,
deeply impressed with
his wisdom and charm.
He considered himself to be as
much a storyteller as musician,
and his song intros at concerts
were often quite elaborate.
Nevertheless,
[ Laughter ]
Do you play, no.
Nevertheless, audiences
hung on every word.
When he led jam sessions,
participants would eagerly
follow wherever he led,
even if they had never before
heard his selected tune
or tune version.
Although Alan was never
a full time musician,
he made incalculable
contributions
to the music world.
While still a graduate
student, he took his reel
to reel recorder off to the
Piedmont and Southern Mountains
and preserved the music of
several important roots fiddlers
on tape, most notably Henry Reed
of Monroe County, West Virginia.
He learned quite a number
of those tunes on fiddle,
and began teaching them to
a coterie of musicians in
and around Chapel
Hill, North Carolina.
Along with Bertram Levy, who
is here tonight, Bobby Thompson
and Tommy Thompson, he founded
the Hollow Rock String Band,
whose recordings and concerts
launched the contemporary old
time music revival.
The Hollow Rock band
and other products
of the Chapel Hill scene,
such as the Fuzzy
Mountain String Band,
you can tell the era, and
the Red Clay Ramblers, same,
introduced many, many
tunes to the old time scene
that have become
beloved classics.
Amongst these tunes are Over
the Waterfall, Frosty Morning,
Kitchen Girl, Ebenezer,
which Alan usually called
West Virginia Highway,
Magpie and Green Willows.
[ Background noise ]
And, as you've heard, he
became the founding director
of the Folklife division,
here at the Library
of Congress, in the 70's.
In that capacity, he promoted
music, and other folk arts,
and supervised the recordings of
many additional roots musicians,
most notably the Hammonds family
of Pocahontas County,
West Virginia.
He also had to interact with
many notable business leaders,
philanthropists and politicians
of the last quarter
of the 20th century.
A fact that led to many
interesting conversation during
our long drives between
tour destinations.
Thinking back on the many
stories and anecdotes
that Alan shared during
our travels, I recently go
to thinking that, perhaps,
one over arching theme
to describe his life was
the notion of the quest.
What brought him to North
Carolina in the first place,
was an impulse to study
someone else's quest.
The topic of his dissertation
was the story of Bear Wolf.
Once there, he became intrigued
by the study of folklore
and ballads, and
inspired by the search
for child ballad melodies among
the singers of Appalachia.
And drawing on his background
as a highly trained
classical violinist,
he embarked on a year's
long quest to locate
and record Appalachian fiddlers
and preserve their tunes.
Alan started with Piedmont
players, like John Lewis,
and then headed deeper
into the mountains.
He encountered a fiddler
named Oscar Wright
and found himself deeply
drawn to his tunes.
Wright told him that the source
of those tunes was old man,
Henry Reed, who not
only was still living,
but could easily be tracked
down in Glen Lyn, Virginia.
[ Background noise ]
Alan often told the story,
you've seen that picture before,
too, Alan often told the story
of how he and Karen drove
up to the Reed residence,
for the first time,
late one afternoon,
knocked on the door,
and were immediately
invited to partake
of a large family dinner,
despite, as Alan puts it,
that Reed had no idea who we
were or why we were there, too,
and be like his gestures.
In any event, after dinner,
the tape recorder came out
and numerous tunes
were recorded,
including one called
West Virginia Gals,
that Alan said moved him
so deeply his musical
life was changed forever.
His next quest was
learning the tunes
and translating them
effectively to fiddle.
Now you should know
that it's not easy
for a classically trained
violinist to play fiddle music.
In fact, now a days, we often
make fun of such people.
[ Laughter ]
The bowing is completely
different, liveliness
and rhythmic attack are far
more important than soaring tone
and following a conductor's
directions.
Nevertheless, Alan
watched and listened
to the old time players he met,
and figured out, not only how
to play these tunes effectively,
but to play them so compellingly
that they attracted a
coterie of collaborators,
entranced a generation
of musicians,
and launched a musical revival.
[ Background noise ]
This said, his take on the tunes
changed as he went through life.
Judging from the first
Hollow Rock LP's,
his early playing was strong and
lively, but as the years went
by the quieted delicacy
of phrasing and lyricality
that were truly unique
in the world
of contemporary folk
music performance.
And I was very fortunate to
come along right at the moment
that this unique approach
to the music was coming
fully into its own.
Alan loved playing with strong
innovative banjo pickers.
And working with him served
as a great inspiration
to numerous influential
banjoists.
Tommy Thompson, there
on the right,
developed a highly percussive,
semi-melodic picking style
to drive the Hollow
Rock String Band sound,
and carried that style
into the Red Clay Ramblers.
Many, many banjo pickers
that came up during the 70's
and 80's cite Tommy's
playing as one
of their main, formative
influences.
Bertram Levy eventually put
aside the mandolin he played
in his Chapel Hill days,
and took up 5 string banjo.
And as he re-explored the
Hollow Rock repertoire,
he developed a new
approach to claw hammer
that can be heard merge
with Alan's fiddling
and James Reed's guitar
playing on the CD,
the Henry Reed Reunion.
And that's Bertram on the right.
He's here tonight.
And then, in the 90's, banjoist
philosopher, Stephen Wade,
who is also here today, and
you'll hear from him in a,
very shortly, was one of Alan's
favorite musical collaborators,
and in fact, a CD made from one
of their live performances
has just been issued.
Alan used to tell quite
a number of stories
about the tunes we played,
some of which reflected
on the vicissitudes of
collecting a repertory
and then observing
from a distance
as individual tunes
became disseminated.
He always regretted, for
example, that he never thought
to ask fiddler John
Lewis about the spelling
of the tune title,
Rose Division.
He wrote down r o s e, like
the flower, but was later left
to wonder could it actually
have been r o w e apostrophe s,
or even r h o d e apostrophe s?
You may remember this musing.
Alan later found out
from, he often talked
about a quirky a modal tune,
originall recorded by Reed,
with no title, but dubbed
Texas by the Hollow Rock crew,
when they put it on an LP,
because of a story
that Reed had told.
Can we hear that audio please?
[ Music ]
Okay. So Alan later found out,
from Reed, that the real name
of the tune was Newcastle.
But despite years of trying
to correct the nomenclature,
people in the old time music
revival could simply not
be budged.
As far as they were concerned,
the name of the tune was
Texas, and that was that.
Another case that bemused him
involved a very sweet lyrical
tune in the key of
g, again collected
from Henry Reed with no title.
Can we have the other tune
on that slide, please?
[ Music ]
Anyway, Alan included
it on a tape he sent
out to the West Coast,
positioned right next
to another tune called
Lady of the Lake.
Somehow things got conflated,
to use one of Alan's
pet expressions,
and the g tune started
spreading on the West Coast
under the title Lady
of the Lake.
Years later, Alan was able
to trace how the tune,
with its newly minted name,
moved from fiddler to fiddler,
until its original provenance
was forgotten and it got
into the hands of a well
known contra dance fiddler
from New Hampshire,
named Rodney Miller.
Miller recorded it on an LP
called New England Chestnuts.
[ Laughter ]
And from that time
on, virtually everyone
in the folk scene has assumed
it was an old New England tune.
This said, as it happens,
the title Lady of the Lake,
fits the tune perfectly.
And the melody is far better
suited for contra dancing
than it is for southern square
dancing, so no harm done.
Alan often compared the
function of tune collectors
to the workings of an hourglass.
In an earlier era, a
given tune might be known
by many musicians, then
as the music culture
declines there were fewer
and fewer players, and
the number of people
who know the tune shrinks,
sometimes to as few
as a single person.
When the collector comes along,
hopefully before that last grain
of sand has disappeared, he or
she teaches the tune to others.
It then comes back to
life and spreads again,
sometimes becoming
even better known
than it was in the first place.
[ Background noise ]
No tune is a better
case in point, here,
than Over the Waterfall.
It was collected from Henry
Reed, a single known source,
and spread so quickly
and pervasively
that few people now a days have
any idea where it came from.
It first appeared as cut
number 7 on the b side
of the first Hollow Rock LP.
Not long afterwards, Alan
moved to L.A. and was asked
to judge a fiddle contest
at nearby Topanga Canyon.
One of the contestants, not
knowing who was judging,
announced that he was
going to play a tune
from the Hollow Rock String
Band called Over the Waterfall.
As Alan put it, that tune
beat me to California.
[ Laughter ]
Flash forward about 15
years, Alan and Karen were
in Hungary attending a music
party, Halvic Injunction
with an Academic Conference,
a band from Brittany was
on center stage when
the word got
out that the tall
American played the fiddle,
Alan was 6 6 in his
stocking feet.
In Alan's words, I saw the
band members talking among
themselves, and I guess
they were probably saying,
what song do we know that the
tall American might also know?
Finally, a young woman
who served as band leader,
turned to Alan and
asked brightly,
can you play, Over
the Waterfall?
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, here's the version
of Over the Waterfall
from the Hollow Rock recording
that, on that fateful,
when that fateful cut was made.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
Maybe we'll get a chance to
play that in the jam session.
Anyway, I'd like to conclude by
playing Billy in the Lowland,
and this is a tune that Alan
and I felt was the best vehicle
for capturing the essence
of our sound, and the tune
that we almost always
used to open our concerts.
Not surprisingly, it was
collected from Henry Reed,
who said it was originally from
east Virginia, which is the way
that West Virginian's refer
to what is now called
the state of Virginia.
[ Laughter ]
[ Background noise ]
I think a tuning would
be appropriate here.
It is a banjo, after all.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Betsy Peterson:
Thank you, so much.
That was really wonderful.
I also want to say, that there
are some CD's in the back
by Ken, both, and by
Stephen Wade who we will here
from in just a second.
They are recordings that are
with Alan, so if you would
like to hear more, please
go back and get a copy.
I'm also looking forward
to hearing more music,
very shortly.
It's wonderful to hear
the full dimensions
of Alan being talked about here.
For some of us, folklore,
as we get sort of mired
in the academic and the
words, it's sure nice
to hear words with music.
Our next speaker is Stephen
Wade, and many of you know him.
He has spent nearly his
entire life in the study
of American folklife, and
he's probably best known
for banjo dancing, a
theatrical performance
that combines storytelling,
traditional music,
and percussive dance,
which was one
of the longest running off
Broadway shows in the country.
Here, at the Library, we are
particularly appreciative
of his book, The Beautiful Music
All Around Us, Field Recordings
and the American Experience,
which showcases nearly
two decades of research,
during which Wade tracked
down the communities, families
and performers connected with
the iconic AFC field recordings,
and do, indeed, demonstrate
how important research is.
The book received the 2013
ASCAP Deem's Taylor Award,
and the Association of
Recorded Sound Collections Award
for Best History.
Wade has released a number
of award winning CD's,
of which the latest is
Americana Concert, Alan Jabbour
and Stephen Wade at the
Library of Congress.
So please, give a warm
welcome to Stephen Wade.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Wade: Alan and
I would always open all
of our shows with
this tune here.
We started playing together,
I met him in 19 mid 70's,
and we started playing
here in DC around 82.
[ Music ]
You're ready there?
All right.
That's Zan McLeod, and he was
a good friend of Alan's, too.
[ Applause ]
When my wife and I got married,
Zan and Alan played that.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you, very much.
Well, as I said, Alan and
I opened our every concert
with that tune, that
he called Stony Point.
But it goes by more
names than that.
These include, Old Vad,
Wild Horse, Celtin's Reel,
Pig Town Fling, Unfortunate
Dog, Buck Creek Girl,
Richmond Ruckus, and when
Earl Scruggs recorded it
with Paul Warren, they
called it Fiddling Banjo.
Back when we performed it,
Alan noted that there'd always
be some accommodating soul,
he said, who would call it
the Wild Horse at Stony Point.
I thought of a way of
approaching this tune
without Alan here to lead it
might reside in that banjo here,
made during the Civil War.
The history that dwells in this
instrument, and the past lives
who once held it, calls to mind
the remark that Alan often made
about Quince Dillion, a fiddler
in fifer from the Mexican War,
who, as an old man,
taught young Henry Reed,
who then decades later, guided
the youthful Alan Jabbour.
Only one person Alan
marveled stood between himself
and that misty figure
of Jacksonian America,
that tenacious thread
still intact extends
to those here tonight,
who in turn learn
their music from Alan.
And thus, ancestries
become continuities.
The epigraph of this new album,
a concert that Alan and I played
at the Coolidge Auditorium
20 years ago,
comes from something Alan wrote.
He said, how complicated
and powerful,
beyond our own imaginings, are
the radiations of what we do.
Alan's thought applies not only
to the influences his
repertory had upon others,
but within the music itself.
Alan exemplified an
approach that Indian fiddler,
John W. Summers, a
contemporary of Henry Reed's,
called the originality
of the tune.
That is, that each piece
possesses a detailed identity.
Dick Summers saw it as
the fiddler's obligation
to learn however many
parts a tune might have,
and to take no shortcuts in
that, in their execution.
Similarly, Buddy Thomas, a
Kentucky fiddler committed
to the older styles, felt
the need to bow the tune out.
The influential radio
fiddler, Georgia Slim Rutland,
likewise spoke of
his mother's council,
when he first started playing.
She said, don't ever
detract from a tune.
Add to it all you want,
but don't take away.
These musicians shared, in
common, a view of fiddle tunes
as complex, self-contained
works.
And that's how Alan
crafted his pieces.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background noise ]
Tonight's invitation also
asks us to also consider Alan
in relation to his
legacy in folk life.
When Alan began his
graduate studies at Duke,
his classroom professor
sometimes played selections
from the folk music
albums issued
by the Library of Congress.
These performances, many
recorded in domestic settings,
did not scrub away the
sounds of those places.
In the background,
sometimes, a dog barks,
a kitchen clock ticks, roosters
crow, a truck drives by,
these records alerted
Alan to the kind
of first person collecting
he soon undertook himself,
nor in the ensuring years,
as head of the folk archive
and later as director of the
American Folklife Center,
did he divorce cultural
expression
from lived experience.
Art is not a thing
apart, he once told me,
it can't be set aside from life.
One song emblematic of
that fusion, and included
on those albums that Alan heard,
comes from Vera Hall, a singer
and domestic worker from
Livingston, Alabama.
In October, 1940, she
recorded for the Library,
Another Man Done Gone,
a blues she learned
from her husband recently
returned from prison.
Well, the well known
number most often appears
as a lover's plaint.
In her rendition, she
largely sang spirituals,
it seemingly becomes
a civil rights anthem.
In what could serve
as a mission statement
for the American Folklife
Center, Vera Hall later said,
any song that we
sing have reference
to the life that we live.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
[ Background noise ]
Well, he closed with a medley.
The first recalls a tune
that Alan played as Patty
on the turnpike, though it,
too, goes by other names.
We follow with Kitchen
Girl, that Alan learned
from Henry Reed and then
transmitted to the world,
and we end with Sheep Shell Corn
by the Rattling of His Horn,
a piece recorded in 1941
for the Library of Congress
by Fiddler Emmett Lundy.
Lundy, born in southwest
Virginia in 1864,
learned from a much older
fiddler named Green Leonard.
He said of Green Leonard, quote,
he didn't teach them tunes
to me, but I catched
them from him.
And in his last days, he told
me that I was the only one
that tracked him
down, and he wanted
to learn me some old
pieces before he died,
he didn't want them
to be buried,
and live after he was done.
Sheep Shell Corn lives
on through Emmett Lundy.
He played it majestically, a
description that applies as much
to Alan Jabbour, this tall swan
of a man, musician, folklorist,
administrator, author and
inspiration to so many.
I hear,
[ Applause ]
I hear now, since he left us,
Alan's courtly words resound,
how complicated and powerful,
beyond our own imaginings,
are the radiations
of what we do.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
That's Zan McLeod.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Betsy Peterson:
Thank you, Stephen.
Thank you, Zan.
[ Background noise ]
And we are coming down
to our last speaker.
I think the Jabbour family
should always have the last
word, before we start hearing
some music, and playing music.
So please do not go away.
But to come down to the, you
know, the practical universe,
if you do need to leave,
there are staff at the back
and will guide you
to the elevators,
and make sure you
get on your way.
And for those of you who stick
around, and play an instrument,
and have an instrument with
you, please don't forget
about those property passes.
We want to make sure
you get out.
So, and then finally, thank you,
Stephen, again, thank you Zan,
thank you, Ken, and thank you
Carl, and thank you, Alan.
Our last speaker is Karen
Jabbour, she's Alan's wife,
love and lifelong research
partner throughout his career.
Their work together
includes rich documentation
of the tradition of Decoration
Day, which was published
in the book, Decoration
Day in the Mountains,
and I think she need
no other introduction.
Karen.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Jabbour: Good evening,
family and many friends.
Welcoming all of you
here has reminded me
of a generous reflection
that Alan's first
administrative assistant,
here at the American
Folklife Center, made.
Eleanor Sreb said that her late
husband didn't leave her a lot
of money, but he left
her very rich in friends.
And I certainly feel
rich in friends tonight.
My thanks to the Folklife Center
staff for their dedication
in bringing about this
tribute to Alan's legacy.
And my heartfelt appreciation
to Carl Fleishhauer,
to David Furchgott, to Ken
Perlman, and Stephen Wade,
and Zan McLeod for their
devotion to portraying for all
of us, in words,
photographs and music,
and their long creative
interaction with Alan.
Finally, thanks to you musicians
who will continue the legacy
in your tribute in
the jam later tonight.
As many of you know, when
Alan retired in 1999,
he took on a project
offered to him
by the National Parks
Service to create a study
of the cultural tradition
of holding cemetery
decoration events
for the environmental impact
statement for a major road
in Great Smokey Mountains
National Park
to the graveyards left
behind by the people
who were moved off the land.
Without Carl to rely on for
documentation, Alan drafted me
as his field collaborator
and photographer.
I can take a picture, this
is my photograph of Alan,
which has been very hard for
me to look in the eye tonight,
because I know he's
looking right at me.
So after 2 years of attending
these cemetery events,
we submitted the study
for the EIS volume.
With so much enthusiasm and
documentation left over,
that we went on to publish a
book in 2010 with University
of North Carolina Press, called
Decoration Day in the Mountains,
which has been mentioned
tonight.
This only wet Alan's appetite
to continue surveying cemeteries
with me, throughout
the entire rural south.
And he completed, before
his death, a second book,
now awaiting my editing, at the
University Press of Mississippi.
In the course of studying
cemetery traditions,
we researched illusions in the
literature, in literature art
and song to cemetery events.
Alan had a special place
in his heart for slow airs,
called hens, played
by southern fiddlers.
When we were doing research
at Boreal College Library,
he heard a solo version
of the 19th century hymn,
the Old Church Yard,
played by Sanford Kelly.
And he recalled an illusion
in John C. Campbell's book,
the Appalachian Highlander
in His Home,
to a congregation
singing this hymn
in a processional
to the cemetery.
Alan noted in Kelly's playing,
the slow, monophonic style
and irregular pulse of the old
unaccompanied singing style.
I'd like to conclude by playing,
for you, Alan's fiddling
of the Old Church Yard, the
final track on his last album,
You Can't Beat the Classics.
The words to the first verse
are, Oh come, come with me
to the old grave yard,
I well know the path
through the soft green sward,
friends slumber we would want
to regard, we'll trace out their
names in the old grave yard.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you, folks, and Ken
will now organize the jam.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay. So here's
a moment a lot
of you have been
looking forward to.
What we're going to do is
everybody whose brought
instruments, this is
your time to go get them.
And we'd like to clear, make
a clearing, kind of here,
a big circle space
that people can come
and join once you've got your
instruments, and others can sit
around and listen
or participate.
But we'd like to clear
some chairs right here,
and make an opening that
people can sit around.
>> The first tune we're going to
play is often called Ebenezer.
And this is collected
from Henry Reed and was
on the first Hollow Rock
album, and Alan said
that Henry Reed often called
it West Virginia Highway.
And if anyone else has
any memories to share.
So we're going to
start this tune.
Do you want to kick it off?
This is Bertram Levy, by the
way, an original Hollow Rocker.
[ Applause ]
>> I should say, right off the
bat, that this is Alan's fiddle.
[ Cheering ]
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Bertram, do you
want to pick a tune?
[ Background noise ]
Yeah, for a little while.
Yeah. So, you know Alan and
I, we were like brothers,
we grew up together
with this music.
I mean, Alan was kind of, I
mean he was the inspiration,
but we were the, 3 or 4 of us
were the people that really kind
of put it all together
and made it come alive
and we shared the tunes
and we shared the whiskey
and the camels and we shared
being bad boys and we.
It was a great experience
and I'll just relate one,
one memory which is
once we visited Henry.
I was his sidekick and I would
go with him to visit some
of these folks and we
visited Henry and took him
down to Narrows and we sat under
a tent and Alan was sitting here
and Bobby Thompson was sitting
here and I was sitting there
and Tommy Thompson
was sitting there
and Henry was sitting there and
he hadn't been out of his house
in many years and
people would all come up
and offer him something to
drink and they'd all go,
they'd point it out
and they say Henry,
that's you when you were young.
So, that was, we knew then
that Alan had the right stuff.
So, this is a beautiful tune
which is John Brown's March.
Remember the 4, begins with
a 4 chord on the second part.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
>> Hey. That wasn't a
Henry V. tune, was it?
It was? Marcie do you have a
tune that you'd like us to play?
[ Background noise ]
>> Well, okay.
Okay, we're going to do
Sheers and Stockings.
Do you have any stories
about that other
than it's a Henry V. tune?
>> I think we actually
named this tune.
I don't think Henry had
a name for it, did he?
Yeah, the title.
There were many tunes that
Henry didn't remember the title
or sometimes we'd play
them with the one title
and then he'd write back to Alan
and he'd say I think that's a
different title, but now that I,
you know, when I, last
time I talked to Alan,
last time I talked to Alan, he,
we were musing about the facts
that during our working we
always wondered while the old
guys never played the fiddle
when they were working.
When they were young men
and only took it up again
when they were older and
then Alan and I were musing
about 6 months before he
passed away and we realized
that we also picked
up the fiddle again
after we stopped working and I
said Alan, we were those guys
and we didn't know it.
We thought we were maybe
documentarians or something,
but we were just
fiddlers just like them
and you probably are the same.
So, this is Sheers
and Stockings.
[ Music ]
>> Okay. Do you have a
tune you'd like to suggest?
>> Green Willis.
>> Green Willis,
you want to do to d?
Banjo players mind going to d?
Okay, but that's all right
we're in the territory.
Okay, so we're going to D
and we're going to
play Green Willis.
[ Background noise ]
>> Okay, we're going
to play Green Willis
and this originated actually as
a jig called the New Rig Ship,
a Scottish tune and during
the late 19th century became a
fifing tune played as
a march or quickstep
in the south called Chapel Hill
Serenade and then it got sped
up into a reel and
that's how we play it now.
So, let's start, you'd be
interested in knowing that.
>> Once Alan and I were
sitting around with Libba Cotton
and she said, I know that
tune, we used to call
that Chapel Hill Serenade
when I lived there.
We used to hear the
fife and drum march
down the street playing
that tune and.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
>> Okay. So, going
around in this end
of the circle, a detune.
How could we not?
So, you've already heard
the story of this one.
Do you know anything more
about Over the Waterfalls
and what I say?
David, you had a story
you wanted to tell about?
>> DAVID DURCHGOTT: All,
all I know about Over
the Waterfall is it comes
from an old English ballad
in which she tried, the,
she wanted to get
rid of her husband
and so she gave him some wine
and blinded him and sat him
by the cliff and then he said,
she said just stand there
and she got back and she
ran to push him over,
but he was a crafty old guy and
he just stepped out of the way
and she went over the waterfall.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
>> Okay, kind of in this end of
the circle, anyone have a tune?
Rocking the Babies
to Sleep, cool.
Can you play that?
All right, you want to lead it?
Okay.
>> You know this [inaudible]
over here, he's the one
who taught it to
Alan didn't you rock,
or you at least Rocking
the Babies to Sleep.
[ Background noise ]
[ Music ]
>> Let's finish up
with Frosty Morning.
Everyone knows Frosty Morning.
[ Music ]
[ Background noise ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.